ahora hablamos de nuestra salud en
directo américa de france 24 ya estaba
marina sardenya con nosotros en el
estudio marina bienvenida buena mañana
de jueves y tenemos en esta crónica más
razones marina para dejar de comer
alimentos ultra procesados porque los
estudios publicados en la revista
british medical journal evidencia que el
consumo de estas comidas preparadas con
riesgo aumentan el riesgo de las
enfermedades graves como el cáncer el
cáncer de los intestinos o muerte
prematura o un mayor riesgo de las
enfermedades cardíacas marina buenos 10
rounds y otra vez nuevos estudios que
evidencian como el consumo de alimentos
ultra procesados está asociado a un
mayor riesgo de padecer enfermedades
crónicas como el cáncer de colon que en
américa es el cuarto tipo de cáncer más
contundente como vimos en esta región de
las américas este tipo de alimentación
incluye productos horneados sandwiches
envasados bebidas gaseosas cereales
azucarados y es que una dieta saludable
es imperativo de una buena salud pero
una alimentación con deficiencias de
nutrientes pues puede costarnos también
la salud y atajar esto debería ser un
tema de salud pública para todos los
gobiernos para hablar de esto tenemos
con nosotros
oscar franco él es profesor de salud
pública de la universidad de berna
buenos días doctor gracias por estar con
nosotros como decimos no es la primera
vez que aparece en este tipo de estudios
en los que relacionan los ultra
procesados con distintas enfermedades
crónicas cuéntanos un poco de qué se
tratan estos dos nuevos estudios y
cuáles son los principales hallazgos
si no es la primera vez sin embargo
estos estudios son de los más grandes
que hemos tenido son estudios que
abarcan casi 200.000 personas o algo más
de 200 mil personas y que estas personas
han sido observadas durante las últimas
tres décadas entonces hay una
observación lo suficientemente larga
para poder determinar si este tipo de
dieta o este tipo de alimentos se podría
relacionar con algo común acumulando las
enfermedades relacionados con el cáncer
o con esa pena hes cardiovasculares o
como calidad entonces lo que encuentra
en estos estudios es que en realidad el
consumo de esos alimentos puede llevar a
un aumento de un 30% en el riesgo de
tener cáncer en particular en los
hombres si como dices este estudio
resaltaba es uno que el 30 por ciento de
los hombres se verían afectados
precisamente por tener una mala
alimentación y con el cáncer de colon
porque l afecta más a los hombres que a
las mujeres este tipo de enfermedades
relacionadas con los alimentos ultra
procesados
si en otros estudios también se han
encontrado relaciones dentro de las
mujeres entonces podría ser un aspecto
particular a este estudio y de otro lado
podría ser aspectos particulares que
diferencian a los hombres ya las mujeres
por ejemplo están las las
características hormonales de las
mujeres que sabemos que hasta el mismo
pau se deciden tienen cierto grado de
protección contra enfermedades con
enfermedad cardiovascular y tiene una
distribución hormonal diferente también
sabemos que las mujeres tienen un estilo
de vida que es mucho más saludable que
el de los hombres tienden a ser más
ejercicio tienden a manejar mejor el
estrés en general esto es en general no
para todas las personas aplican y por
último vemos como las mujeres pues
dentro de esos productos ultra
procesados es posible que consuman más
otros alimentos como los yogures o
consumo de productos lácteos o de otro
tipo de alimentos que sean ultra
procesados pero que podrían ser
contener un poco menos de aditivos u
otros productos que podrían ser peores
que he comparado con la con el tipo de
productos que consumen los hombres es
decir que en efecto evidencia entonces
el estudio de doctor que nosotros los
hombres estamos más afectados por esta
mala alimentación mala alimentación
malas nutrientes que las mujeres
lo que vemos es el primero que es
posible que sea por nuestro estilo de
vida como hombres que tenemos un estilo
de vida diferente los hombres tienden a
fumar más hacer menos ejercicio manejar
menos el estrés también podría ser
aspectos hormonales pero por ahora lo
que estamos hallazgo es hallando en este
estudio en particular es que en realidad
la asociación se observó únicamente en
los hombres y en las mujeres pero esto
lo tenemos que tener poner en dentro del
contexto y evaluarlo en poblaciones
adicionales para poder tener esa
confirmación doctor y otro estudio
apunta a que el consumo de estos
alimentos nocivos o dañinos con un 27%
más de riesgo de muerte cardiovascular
hay una relación causa-efecto entre este
tipo de alimentación que como decíamos
al principio está basada pues en en
productos
gaseosos azúcares
altos en contenido en grasa con las
enfermedades cardiovasculares
si estabas ha encontrado una relación
fuerte con ce frenadas cardiovasculares
con la obesidad también con altos
niveles de mortalidad y ahora con cáncer
también y hay varias teorías hay varias
hipótesis que confirman lo que podrían
asignar las posibles rutas en cómo estos
alimentos podrían llevar a un aumento de
riesgo por un lado está el aspecto
inflamatorio que estos alimentos usted
ha procesado se relaciona con un mayor
nivel de niveles crónicos de inflamación
segundo algunos de los aditivos que se
utilizan pueden ser dañinos para la
salud pueden hacer por ejemplo
cancerígenos y estos aditivos podrían
ser es parte de la causa por lo cual se
podría aumentar el riesgo de
enfermedades cardiovasculares pero
también en este caso del cáncer y
también por otro lado es que mientras
que se consumen estos productos se dejan
de consumir otros productos que pueden
ser más saludables y que podrían traer
más beneficios para las personas
entonces la causa y efecto aunque está
todavía en investigaciones está
confirmando y es muy difícil hacerlo en
nutrición las teorías de los hallazgos
y en estos estudios mucho más largos y
mucho más amplios tienden a indicar que
en realidad hay una causa y efecto entre
estos alimentos super procesados y alto
riesgo a enfermedades cardiovasculares
mortalidad del cáncer doctor como
siempre gracias por estar con nosotros
en nuestro espacio de salud en directo
américa de francés 24 también gracias
marina por acompañarnos el doctor oscar
franco asesor científico de nuestro
canal pasamos a saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada el día